restrictive dietary patterns are not
good for your gut microbiome
the single greatest predictor of a
healthy gut microbiome is the diversity
of plants when you restrict specific
food groups particularly when it comes
to restriction of plants because that's
where the dietary fiber is
when you
restrict these food groups
you
basically stop feeding the microbes that
thrive on those particular types of
foods elimination diets when properly
implemented are a powerful tool for
identifying the root of our problems the
problem is when we like to permanently
eliminate
thinking oh i can't eat that food well
that's not true
right you are capable of consuming that
food how do you get there though we
that's where we train our gut so i've
already started to make an analogy
between food intolerances and our gut
and exercise yeah think of your gut like
a muscle
it can be trained
it can be made stronger there is no food
that i want you to sustain unless
there's some different medical reason
that we haven't identified yet like
celiac disease
that was dr will bolsowicz an exciting
follow-up conversation from our previous
episode discussing the importance of
plant diversity to optimize our
microbiome and overall health he's an
incredible gastroenterologist who
recently came out with his second book
the fiberfield cookbook available now
i'll link it below for anyone who'd like
to get it i myself cannot wait to get my
hands on this book in this episode we go
even deeper to get into the layered
complexities of the gut and our
individuality how to heal from food
intolerances and live in abundance
without restriction and the importance
of other lifestyle factors like stress
that directly impacts our gut health his
expertise is a blend of medical research
with a holistic emphasis for a combined
and maximum impact i know you're gonna
love this conversation so let's get into
it welcome to the podcast welcome back
dr b to round two i am so excited to get
into this way further than we did even
before yeah i mean i felt like the first
round was incredible and i'm excited to
um
focus this time around on
not just explaining but actually jumping
into solutions yes absolutely because it
really even though there's so much
information it still felt like we barely
scratched the surface so someone might
be like okay dr b i understand
the why but then where do i go from here
right you know that's what we need to
focus on because you know one of the
important things that i want people to
understand is that
i embrace
our uniqueness
each one of us is a unique individual
that's a beautiful thing right like if i
were married to myself i would drive
myself crazy
i'm glad that my wife is different than
me
and the the same is true when it comes
to our diet which is that i embrace that
there is no one-size-fits-all
that we need an approach that allows us
to navigate navigate ourselves towards a
better diet that works for us and brings
us great joy and so that's kind of what
i want to focus on today if that's cool
with you of course and so before we get
into these like questions to really
break it down and get into the
nitty-gritty for those who are just
tuning in for the first time just
hearing about you for the first time or
learning like what you're all about what
you advocate for in the last episode we
did together you talked about the
importance of eating a wide variety of
whole plant foods can you just explain
why that is for the people who are just
now tuning in sure a hundred percent so
hello everyone i'm dr wilbul sowitz i am
a gastroenterologist and um also the new
york times bestselling author of a book
called fiberfield and
in fiberfield my book uh that came out
in may of 2020
i actually described this as the golden
rule
i feel like we have made diet so
complicated
how about just one rule that's it
eat the most wide broad variety of
plants
that you possibly can
and the reason that this is so important
is that living inside of us are 38
trillion microbes
and they're there to support us as
humans they're actually deeply
intertwined with our digestion our
immune system metabolism the balance of
our hormones our mood our brain health
even the expression of our genetic code
they are absolutely vital
to human health and they're not even
human
nor are they a part of our body
and the beautiful
exciting redeeming thing about these
microbes
is that no matter what your sins of the
past may be
they will forgive you
because you have the ability to shape
them
to form them
but what is the most powerful way to
accomplish this
science has shown us
from the american gut project which is
the
number one largest trial to date to
allow us to make connections between our
diet and lifestyle choices
and the health of our gut microbiome
in the american gut project they found
that there was a clear-cut single most
powerful predictor of a healthy gut
microbiome
and that is the diversity of plants
within your diet
when you eat a wider array of plants as
many different varieties as possible
each one of these plants has unique
types of fiber
not all fiber is the same
and fiber which you will find in every
single plant every plant has fiber and
also mushrooms mushrooms technically are
not plants but i
think of them as honorary plants because
they have fiber
in there you will find the fiber and the
fiber is the preferred food of your gut
microbes but not all microbes eat the
same fiber and not all fiber from every
plant is the same thing
that's like saying the protein in a fish
is the same as the protein in a bean
that's not true
so what we need is we need a wide
variety of different types of fiber
that we get from a wide variety of
plants
to feed
a wide variety of microbes
the concept ends up like taking complex
you know microbiome science
the rule
ends up being quite simple
diversity of plants on the plate
translates into diversity of microbes in
your gut
and that is a measure of a healthy gut
yeah that's fascinating i think most
people aren't even considering that like
we're just not really told or even just
explained that information
growing up it definitely wasn't
something on my radar like learning how
many types of plants i eat
the issue is that the
if you're not being a conscious consumer
which i spent most of my life just kind
of going along
eating what is
normal
if you're not a conscious consumer the
food industry is not going to do this
for you
so this may be your biology this may be
a path that can bring you great health
and happiness and it can be a diet full
of abundance without restrictions that
that you know allows you to accomplish
all your health goals
but the issue is that 75 of the calories
that are produced by the food industry
come from literally three plants right
and so
they're not going to try to make this
more broad and diverse if anything they
want to
restrict the variety in your diet
because it's easier for them as a food
industry
and so it has to be something that we
take upon ourselves we have to be the
ones to correct that mistake
within our own life through our daily
dietary choices but it's not actually
that hard
you just have to keep this top of mind
when you're in the supermarket when
you're at the salad bar when you're
cooking up a pot of soup or a bowl of
chili
or a curry
when you're sitting down at the table
and you have choices in terms of what
goes on your plate you just remember
the single golden rule diversity of
plants and that's it so i think a lot of
people are probably tuning in who are
tuning in are maybe having gut related
issues and they might be going that
sounds all great dr b but when i eat raw
cabbage when i eat beans my digestion
doesn't feel well or i experience this
type of flare-up or whatever so how do
we get to the root cause of our symptoms
and can you lay the groundwork for like
how how to take charge of your health
and heal your gut through this principle
yeah so um this is the end point this is
the goal but that doesn't mean that it's
easy for all of us and the reality is
that every single one of us has a gut
microbiome that is first of all unique
so it's as unique as a fingerprint
there is literally no one on this planet
including your sister
including your parents including your
children
that have the same microbiome as you
ellen
and mine is unique too
um so that unique gut microbiome will
have strengths and weaknesses
and for some people those weaknesses may
be in their ability to digest and
process certain foods
they may find that they struggle
and that actually is indicative
of a gut microbiome that is struggling
because when the gut microbiome is on
its game
then you can eat foods in normal amounts
and feel totally fine now that's not to
say that there aren't limits
right like
if i do something completely absurd
like try to eat you know
two heads of cabbage and one two heads
of cabbage in one meal and nothing else
right i'm pretty sure i'm not gonna feel
very well after doing that but that's
not a normal amount of food so
um so with regard to like these food
intolerances
you know the issue honestly ellen is
that
as a gastroenterologist i have seen
these people like literally on a daily
basis right and these are the people
that i my life is dedicated towards
trying to help them
and i
felt compelled to try to create a
solution so what i did is i
actually made my second book
which just came out called the
fiberfields cookbook amazing i had the
opportunity to make a cookbook okay cool
like 125 plant-based recipes
full-color photography
completely delicious completely abundant
focused on diversity of plants
that's there
but what i really wanted to do as a
medical doctor was to create a solution
more than just something for the people
whose gut is already healthy
i wanted something for the people who
are struggling because
you and i have talked about this before
ellen
the person who needs this the most
is the person who actually struggles the
most
to implement it
because their gut is in an impaired
state
at baseline
and so because their gut has been
injured
it's hard for them to start cranking up
the plants
because
in order to crank up the plants your gut
needs to be able to keep up so i have a
question then to
go along with that what causes a gut to
become so damaged right so
um
it's a complex issue
there are a number of different things i
i think it's important for us to first
look at the food that goes in our mouth
because every single bite of food that
we put into our mouth ultimately is
going to pass through 20 to 25 feet of
intestine
and come into contact with these gut
microbes along that path
and
if we look at the breakdown of the
american diet
i would make an argument that it is a
combination of what is missing
and also what is excessive
so what is missing is fiber
95 of americans are not consuming even
the
minimal recommended amount of fiber
the average woman is getting about 15
grams of fiber per day
when the recommended amount is 25 grams
the average man is getting 18 grams of
fiber per day
when the recommended amount is 38 grams
we're not close
and the fiber we already said at the top
of the show today
that this fiber is actually critical for
feeding and nourishing these gut
microbes so
that's one of the things that's missing
but flip side like what are we replacing
so we're dropping our fiber
right only 10 of our calories come from
plants
what are we doing instead
well one of the things we're doing is
we're really cranking up the ultra
processed foods
so in the american diet about 60 percent
of our calories come from ultra
processed foods ultra processed means
like you can't make this at home
even if you're a skilled chef right
there is no way for you to do this ultra
processed means that
there are food scientists
working in a lab
for 18 months
trying to figure out how to make this
possible
using a combination of things that at
the start are natural
and adding in chemicals that are not
right
and so
i'm not here to say that every single
ultra-processed food is inherently
unhealthy i think that that would be
perhaps going a little too far and being
unfair
it's more so to say that first of all
when 60 of your calories are ultra
processed foods
and these are foods that did not exist a
hundred years ago
we are exposing our gut microbiome to
things that it was not really taught how
to handle
and we're doing it on such a massive
scale
but also the other thing is that there
are 10 000 chemicals in our food supply
they can come of many different
varieties
you know additives colorants
preservatives go down the line
humectants you go down the line there's
so many different types
there's 10 000 of them
we allow them into the food supply
through a process called
grass
generally recognized as safe
and this is like a free pass for the
food industry
right so if this were a drug we would
require them to do a very expensive
phase three clinical trial
but the food industry says we don't have
the money for that
right
so we create a loophole called the g-ras
where like they're not even required to
do a human study wow in fact
about 80
of the things in the food supply
i've never even had a human study wow i
did not know that yeah and so they will
like literally
um
punch this through
based upon
a narrative
or an argument
right we think this is safe because
and it's always
we think yeah because you don't have
human studies to back it up
and when you do have human studies it's
like oh well
you know these people ate this food for
two weeks and they're okay right so
therefore we are satisfied right what
happens if you eat that for 40 years
yeah we don't know we just don't know
right right but the problem is that when
there are when there are exposures going
on for decades and there's 10 000 of
them
how do we and it's like 60 of your
calories how do we
like untie that knot yeah and figure out
which ones are doing what
that's like nearly impossible
so
you know i'm concerned
that some of these things
are causing harm causing injury to our
gut
and then the flip side the other thing
is
so 10 of our calories come from plants
60 come from ultra processed foods
what's left what's left is just animal
products
so 30 of our calories come from animal
products that includes eggs dairy and
meat
the average american eats 220 pounds of
meat per year we are if not the number
one it depends on the year
but like if we're not the number one
consumers then we're like number two
so basically our only competition or
other english speaking countries the uk
and the australians are the other big
heavy meat consumers
uh compared to china
like they're consuming a fraction of
what we do right but they're starting to
crank it up
and this is part of the reason why the
amazon rainforest is being burned is to
create space for animal agriculture yeah
nonetheless
the issue is that you know we eat 220
pounds
of meat per year
what's the fiber content of 220 pounds
zero
so we're not getting any fiber from that
we're not getting fiber from the ultra
processed foods we are not getting an
adequate amount of the
fruits vegetables whole grains seeds
nuts and legumes
and then here we end up in this
situation where you know
we eat a thousand pounds of food per
year
but it's so weak when it comes to fiber
it's so weak in terms of the parts that
support a healthy gut and it's so
full
of the stuff that could be causing harm
that it's completely unbalanced right
and it's no wonder that our gut microbes
end up unbalanced as a result of that
so can we go into a little bit about or
a lot of it about people who are trying
to heal their gut and they go down this
road of like an elimination diet
and what are your thoughts on that
where should we go from there for people
who go down this road they're like oh
i'm actually feeling better if i'm just
eating chicken and rice and carrots and
that's all i'm eating or this and this
and this like what what does that mean
is that actually helping the root cause
is that actually healing their gut or
how can people get out of that because
most people don't want to end up eating
just a few foods yeah
um so one of the things that i am super
excited about with my new book the fiber
fields cookbook is that i'm an
introducing approach an approach for
people to take to heal and reverse their
food intolerances
and it's actually an acronym which is
the growth strategy g-r-o-w-t-h
growth from my perspective is a very
important word
right like this is a mindset
that i want people who are in my tribe
to like
have a growth mindset
abundance is another way of saying that
i'm so about that too but flip side uh
or you know in this case
it's an acronym and my approach teaches
people how to fix this and i just want
to comment on this real quick
to frame the conversation about
restrictive diets
so growth stands for g genesis what is
the root cause of the problem we have to
start there
so
we can't really fix something if we
don't know what we're treating
r-o-w i put together
restrict observe work it back in
i'm going to comment on that more in a
moment
and then finally t and h
t stands for train your gut
h stands for holistic healing
so
this restrict observe work it back in
let me start with this
restrictive dietary patterns are not
good for your gut microbiome
period
the single greatest predictor of a
healthy gut microbiome is the diversity
of plants
restriction is to reduce dietary
diversity
and what what happens if you restrict
your plants like what's the outcome like
maybe at first they're feeling well or
they're you know having an ease of
symptoms but what do you think based on
the research you've done
what does it show is going to happen
long term we've seen a pattern that
keeps in different ways a manifestation
of the same pattern that keeps showing
up in our studies
when you restrict specific food groups
particularly when it comes to
restriction of plants because that's
where the dietary fiber is
when you
restrict these food groups
you
basically stop feeding the microbes that
thrive on those particular types of
foods and they're not replaceable you
can't expect like the consumption of
kale to compensate for the absence of
black beans
it's not going to work that way there
are specific microbes that want black
beans
and if you eliminate the beans
those microbes don't get to eat
and when they don't eat
they grow weaker and weaker
to the point that they become less well
represented this is what we see in the
studies you will see that they are less
well represented
in some cases they become undetectable
it's almost as if they're not there
they may still be there but they're so
weak that you don't even see them there
and then it makes sense if you try to
eat it again you're like oh i feel
terrible see i can't eat that food that
food's not good for me that's 100 true
we rely on those specific microbes to
help us to process and digest those
specific foods
and it's much like exercise
if i stop doing curls to work on my
biceps my biceps will get weaker
and i could work on the rest of my body
right i could do all the other exercises
but if i stop doing curls my biceps will
get weaker and there is no replacement
you can't like do some sort of tricep
workout and expect that your biceps grow
stronger it doesn't work that way
right so the biceps grow weaker and then
when i go to reintroduce exercise
and i start doing curls again
i have to substantially reduce the
amount of weight that i'm capable of
lifting
because if i don't do that i'm going to
hurt myself right right i'm no longer
capable of curling 45 pounds like i used
to
now i'm down to curling
10 pounds
right so two things i want to say when
we were talking about the root cause of
something and you're talking about ultra
processed foods and the lack of fiber in
the diet is also antibiotics having
playing a role at all so in terms of the
root cause of like what is causing
people to have an injured gut microbiome
we could go very broad
um so i was talking about food but there
is no question that antibiotics
right the quickest way to change your
gut microbiome is through antibiotics
and one of the issues with antibiotics
is that they're
widely prescribed and actually our
evidence our research suggests that many
times
not even necessary right that's the
issue when they are necessary they are
good right
but when they are not necessary then you
are causing harm to your body that you
don't need right
um there are other medications that have
been shown to negatively affect our gut
microbiome the most commonly used
medications that we have are the
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
like ibuprofen right right and that's
been shown to affect our gut
the top 10 most prescribed medicines
if you look
in that list are several different
proton pump inhibitors
they're used to treat acid reflux stuff
like that right
these drugs have been shown to change
their gut microbiome and then if you're
expanding even further from what we've
already talked about could like
like a food poisoning be a thing or
stress
all those things affecting your gut in
such a way so people are understanding
where did this come from
just like before we get into more like
how to heal it just i want to expand a
little bit more on that yeah totally so
um
uh there are a number of different
lifestyle factors that can negatively
affect our gut microbiome i will come
back to food poisoning in a moment
because that's more of like an acute
issue super specific yeah it's very
specific as opposed to
uh your day-to-day like lifestyle habits
yeah right because when you have a habit
if it's a habit that's a negative habit
then it's like basically repeatedly
traumatizing your gut
right so like the absence of sleep
staying up too late
uh exposure to bright lights late in the
evening
right many people are like on their
phone on their tablet late at night and
it actually affects your sleep hormones
like melatonin right and then your sleep
is not as restful and because your sleep
is not as restful your gut microbiome
suffers a consequence right have you
looked into red light therapy no this is
random but have you ever looked into
that not ingredients
i think red light therapy is fascinating
but okay cool so moving on then in
regards to how your growth the growth
acronym when you restrict and then
observe so you're talking about like a
temporary restricting can you go more
into that yeah yeah so um well one of
the big issues is that there's been this
emergence of
home testing for food intolerances
so there are a bazillion people like
literally 20 of people at least in the
united states have food have chronic
food intolerances wow 20 percent and so
that's um like at least 75 million
people just in the u.s alone why is that
though is that because of all the things
we just talked about i think it's the
harm that we've done to the gut
microbiome and and by the way with
regard to harm to the gut microbiome
going beyond sleep like
absence of sleep
uh sedentary lifestyle stress exercising
stress
and then real quick i just want to
comment on the um gastroenteritis like
getting a bug a stomach bug right like
you go to mexico you get a stomach bug
you come home
it's been three weeks you're still
having symptoms
what's going on
well what's actually happening in that
particular case which has been very well
documented
is that
when you have that sort of acute
inflammatory injury to the gut
microbiome
in a person who's vulnerable and
susceptible
it actually causes a change to the gut
microbiome
and then like the the bug is gone
right the virus or the bacteria are gone
right but the symptoms persist
because you have caused injury to the
gut right and they actually call this
call this post-infectious irritable
bowel syndrome and it's been very well
documented that people will get an
infection
get sick
and then afterwards they get ibs
and have ongoing issues
from that point forward wow
so anyway um so moving on to this
restrict observe work it back in yeah so
the problem is that like there's all
these companies that want to sell you an
at-home test and they want to make a lot
of money like they're they're designed
for profit
yeah but
like that that's fine like i have
nothing against companies who are
designed for profit if they're offering
you something that brings value to your
life and enriches your life right
but there has to be
proof
that what they're selling you actually
works yeah
because if what they're selling you
doesn't
work then it just confuses you and it's
actually causing you to eliminate
certain foods and therefore causing more
of a problem right you eliminate the
foods based upon a test on what they
told you to eliminate that is not
validated
and you don't feel any better but um
what you have done is you've actually
made your gut less healthy yeah through
this restrictive pattern and i see
people all the time who they come in
with like this packet of results you
know it could be 96
antibody tests through blood or it could
be a poop test where they tell you hey
eat this not that
the problem is that like
all right so shout out to everyone who's
listening at home if you've done one of
these tests i understand like
you're just trying to find solutions
you're trying to advocate for yourself
and i love that yeah
um
but
did you find this is to the people at
home did you find
that
the foods they told you that you were
intolerant of
you're like
i don't know what you're talking about i
have no issue there
and then flip side did you also find
that foods that you like clearly have a
problem with
they said oh there's no problem here
nothing to see here yeah right so
this is what i have seen time and time
again is that people take these tests
and it just confuses them and misinforms
them and these are not validated tests
by by not validated it means that show
me the research right
so what does work
the gold standard approach is what i'm
offering
restrict observe work it back in
basically what i'm saying
temporary
not like sustained elimination there is
no food that i want you to sustain
unless there's some different medical
reason that we haven't identified yet
like celiac disease right right that's
different and unique but for the average
person i don't want you to eliminate
foods uh permanently
but if we can go through this process of
temporarily removing the food
seeing how you feel
and then bringing the food back
seeing how you feel
all right and keeping track of that
by flipping the switch
on off on off
it allows us to create these um
uh polar opposites in terms of whether
the food is present or not present
and it allows us to make an assessment
what is the effect of this food how long
of a window should you expect to start
seeing uh an aftermath from the food
you're eating or avoiding um like where
it would be a negative effect or a
positive either okay typically within
two weeks
typically within two weeks you should
notice so like a a two week temporary
restriction um you don't really wanna
like go much beyond that right so but to
do it for two weeks i think is
completely the reason as long as that we
have this mutual upper understanding up
front that this is going to be a
temporary thing yeah you're going to
reintroduce it and you're going to be
interested and and one of the things
that i really want to get across to
people because this is this is actually
the way that elimination diets were
meant to be
elimination diets when properly
implemented are a powerful tool for
identifying the root of our problems
the problem is when we like permanently
eliminate thinking oh i can't eat that
food well that's not true
right you are capable of consuming that
food how do you get there though we
that's where we train our gut right
right so after we restrict observer
worker back in we identify what food we
have a problem with right we also
identify
how much we're capable of tolerating
because the question is not like can you
tolerate it at all
right a person who has severe lactose
i intolerance still put a drop of milk
on their tongue they're not going to
have blowout diarrhea right right now if
they have a food allergy
that's a different story a food allergy
is different right but i'm talking about
an intolerance and if that's what you
have then there is a threshold there's a
certain amount right so let's identify
which foods we cannot consume in an
adequate like normal amount
okay now we've we are empowered
knowing what foods are our food
intolerances that is very useful right
number two how much
that's something we look at during this
process of restrict observe work it back
in when we work back in
how much do you work back in before you
start to have symptoms right okay
once we have that
we now want to take that information
and we want to grow stronger
we want to heal these issues we want to
go beyond these restrictions that we
have
and the way that we approach this is
very similar to exercise so i've already
started to make an analogy between food
intolerances and our gut
and exercise yeah think of your gut like
a muscle
it can be trained
it can be made stronger
it can do things that you don't even
think that you're capable of doing
that's really empowering because i think
that's not something we hear very much
like it's very like oh you can't eat
this like now you never get to eat it
again
and now a word from our sponsors
we're brought to you today by buffy you
guys i'm telling you every time a friend
or guest lays down in these sheets and
comforter they are blown away by how
soft and cozy it is
and i can say without a doubt that buffy
enhances my sleep so in addition to that
what's so great about buffy is that they
are dedicated to making a positive
impact on not only our sleep but also
the environment using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed
their debut product the cloud comforter
is covered in super soft eucalyptus
fabric and filled with fluffy fiber made
from 100 recycled bottles this comforter
has over 18 thousand five star reviews
it keeps you at the perfect temperature
so you feel cozy without overheating and
it is by far my favorite comforter i've
ever slept with it's hypoallergenic and
machine washable thanks to an innovative
stitching batter that keeps its fluffy
fill in place plus its high thread count
shuts out dust mold and mites for a
healthier sleep environment the best
part for me though is that the average
down comforter harms 12 geese but
buffy's comforter is made cruelty free
it feels even softer than down while
keeping approximately 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans so use my code
ellen for twenty dollars off orders over
eighty dollars you can try comforter in
your own bed for free if you don't love
it return it at no cost we're also
brought to you today by bite i'm
obsessed with bite toothpaste bits for
so many reasons
not only do you avoid the harsh
chemicals artificial flavors and
preservatives that you get from
conventional toothpaste you also get to
avoid the plastic waste from using
bottled toothpaste as well that's why
bite makes toothpaste tablets made with
clean ingredients that are sulfate palm
oil and glycerin free and on top of that
the jars are so pretty it comes in
refillable glass jars and they send
refills and compostable pouches so
they're better for our bodies and our
earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it will turn into
paste just like you're used to but with
no plastic tube or messy paste which
makes it extra convenient for kids who
think popping a bite in their mouth is
so fun and makes tooth brushing time a
pleasant experience it honestly felt a
little weird at first but now my whole
family is obsessed it's so effective and
makes my teeth extremely clean i ran out
of bite toothpastes once so i went back
to my old regular toothpaste and very
quickly i realized that my teeth didn't
feel as clean so i'm never going back to
pace and will be using bite from here on
out and my holistic dentist fully
approves bite makes plastic free
alternatives for everything on your
bathroom sink so you can cut out the
harsh chemicals and plastic waste
without compromise and bite is offering
my listeners 20 off your first order go
to
trybite.com
ellen or use the code ellen at checkout
to claim this deal that's t-r-y-b-i-t-e
dot com slash ellen totally and like
think about the person who
has accomplished their fitness goals
right think about the person who like
the guy who can lift you know such huge
amounts of weight in the gym
that you're like oh man that's insane
right or the person who's a runner and
they are running such a great time for
their mile yeah
they don't wake up one day
roll out of bed
and receive a gift from god that allows
them to do that yeah they may have some
talents
we all have talents we all have
strengths and weaknesses
but what they have is they have the
decision that they want to focus on this
make themselves stronger make themselves
more capable
enhance their functional abilities
and so they go through a process of
training
and you might train for a marathon which
is different than training to grow
strong
when it comes to food intolerances we
want to train your gut
we want to add ability to your gut in
the same way that a person who can't
bench press 150 pounds
if they work through a process
and they start at 100 pounds
not only can they get to 150
they could get to 250 they just have to
stay with it and keep following the
process right so with the the process is
like basically the same when it comes to
food intolerances
when you challenge the gut like your gut
is adapted to the food that you are
eating right now
all right so whatever that diet has been
for the last four weeks
your gut is up to the task
of taking on that particular diet
but if you change your diet
and you start doing something different
you're asking your gut to do something
that it wasn't adapted to do and if
that's a radical change then you're
asking your gut to like keep up with a
radical change but you're not giving it
time to make that adaptation
so let's make small changes
just like exercise
if you go to the gym and you start low
enough
there is an amount that you can do
start low
that's awesome just like exercise when
you want to build something stronger
what do you do you increase it slowly
go slow we want to start low and go slow
to build up the strength of our gut and
by doing that we can take something that
we're intolerant to
and we can add functionality to the
point that we are now able to tolerate
it
and then we can continue to add
functionality where we get to the point
where we can tolerate it without
restriction right so you brought up
dairy as an example when you're talking
about food intolerances do you feel like
because i know that is something where
people say that they have an intolerance
to it but then they're able to work it
back in is that something you also would
include in your
way to build up the gut or do you feel
like that's something that might
necessarily you'd be able to tolerate
but isn't necessarily going to help you
long term for your health so i i
personally don't consume dairy i don't
see the value to myself in terms of
consuming dairy so i choose not to i
don't believe that it is a
health-promoting food
but i do think that it's important
to recognize that
dairy has been
very well studied in terms of lactose
intolerance because that is probably the
most common food intolerance that exists
and what we see in the research where
we're looking at and studying lactose
intolerance provides insights into what
happens with because lactose is a
carbohydrate like it's
basically the only carbohydrate that
exists in animal products
so
what we see with lactose intolerance can
be applied to other
carbohydrates that may give people
symptoms like for example the
galactans in beans like some people get
issues with beans that's because there's
carbohydrates in there that can cause
issues
some people get symptoms with wheat or
with whole grains that's because there's
specific things called fructans
that can cause symptoms and these things
are not intended to be vilified
they're actually food for our microbiome
but when your gut is not able to keep up
then you can struggle to process and
digest these foods
with lactose
we have evidence number one
that for people that have lactose
intolerance
there is an approach
what i'm saying start low go slow where
they can introduce milk and by
introducing milk in that way they're
able to build up their lactose tolerance
they're able to consume larger amounts
of milk than they thought they were
capable of again like i'm not advocating
for people to do that
but it illustrates the point
additionally we also have evidence that
if you take a person who
has lactose intolerance
and you actually treat them with a fiber
supplement
so like
at this point it's not even treating the
lactose directly
it's actually treating the gut
when you treat the gut with that fiber
supplement you
restore the gut
and you restore the gut
you actually become more capable of
consuming lactose
so in that study people reintroduced
lactose at a much higher dose than they
thought they were capable of
digesting after first healing their gut
so the point being that you know these
um
food intolerances are the manifestation
of a damaged gut
the goal is to heal the gut
and one of the ways that we do that is
by introducing that food low and slow
training our gut to handle it
but the other thing that we do is we
focus more broadly on how do we optimize
and heal our gut microbiome
right
cool that's so fascinating so people
might be thinking well then why would
you even eliminate meat or eggs or any
of the animal foods because it's not you
know keeping a wide variety
what are your thoughts on that the
single greatest predictor of a healthy
gut microbiome was specifically the
diversity of plants right there is not
evidence that i have seen that indicates
or suggests that there is a benefit to
our gut from maintaining
the consumption of animal products
part of the reason why is because if you
go to look at what are considered
prebiotic
prebiotic is our word that we use for
food for the gut microbes
if you go to look to see what is
prebiotic fiber is prebiotic
there's no fiber in animal products only
plants
resistant starches are prebiotic
there's no resistant starches in animal
products only plants
polyphenols are probiotic polyphenols
are like what give the plants their
colors
right so like yellow red
purple
there's specific phytochemicals
specific plant compounds
that facilitate that
these are the polyphenols polyphenols
are probiotic
there's no polyphenols in animal
products except
like
the cow
eats
more grass
instead of grain
that cow will have
small amounts of residues of the
polyphenols
uh in the meat
because they were eating grass right
right so like if you want to get
minuscule amounts of polyphenols
because directly to the source the cow
was eating grass then then so be it but
like why would you do that
when you could just go straight to the
source and eat a salad right well i
think that that causes like a greater
argument where you're wondering on all
the different
supposed benefits of eating animal foods
and if there are long-term negative
effects to eating like large quantities
of animal foods
as opposed to just looking at like the
polyphenols right i mean we
um
the united states spends
substantially more money per person on
health care than any other country in
the world
the number two country is less than half
the amount that we spend per person
right
and we are
last i checked like number 36 in terms
of life expectancy
and there are countries like costa rica
that like we spend you know
12
15
of what we do on health care
and
they have an equal life expectancy to us
on a diet that is
whole grains
and legumes
so
um
i mean i kind of feel like the status
quo is a total failure
right like we have unhealthy people even
though we are the most affluent country
in the world with the most health care
spending in the world
and
this is the result of like a diet that
is 60 ultra processed foods and 30
animal products i mean if you think that
we're a healthy society then so be it
stick with what we got but i think
something needs to give right so can you
touch on a little bit about carnivore
diets and people who who feel like they
have put their
autoimmune
issues into remission by excluding all
plants and they find that the more
plants they exclude the better they feel
and maybe that's a short-term better
feel like um
feeling better
but what are your thoughts on that
so um
a couple of a couple of thoughts with
regard to this
first of all there are no
actual studies
to say like no one has published a paper
using the carnivore diet to
prevent or treat autoimmune diseases
there are anecdotes right right just
like there are anecdotes that you know a
90 year old man who smokes two packs a
day and drinks 12 back every day and
lives to 90 years old does that mean
that like he lived to 90 because he
smoked that much and drank that much
that being said with the carnivore diet
there is one quality to this diet that i
do think
is very valuable and i have to
acknowledge it
right in the interest of
complete honesty which is that they
eliminate ultra-processed foods yeah and
i'm worried that the ultra-processed
foods there was a study that came out
recently
that made the connection between the
diagnosis of autoimmune diseases and the
consumption of ultra-processed foods
i'm worried that these ultra-processed
foods are driving
these autoimmune diseases because
they're creating confusion of our immune
system because our immune system has
never been exposed to these chemicals
that it's being exposed to on a daily
basis now
right so i do think that there is that
value but the problem is
that you are forced
to make a compromise with your health in
order to take this approach
and it's a compromise that you don't
need to take
the consumption of animal products like
show me a person
who eats a carnivore diet that does not
have a completely ridiculous ldl
cholesterol
because the consumption of saturated fat
on that level is going to drive your ldl
through the roof
and that is and widely accepted cardiac
risk factor for the number one cause of
death
coronary artery disease
if you want to be the person who's the
guinea pig
and takes that chance of eating a
long-term carnivore diet
see what happens in 5 10 20 years if
that's what you want to do
i do wish you well i just don't think
it's a good idea right the science
overwhelmingly says that this is a poor
choice
yeah the number two cause of cancer
death in america is colorectal cancer
the world health organization has
labeled processed meats as a carcinogen
for colorectal cancer the world health
organization also says that red meats
are a probable carcinogen
so again increasing your risk you're
making compromises that i think are
dangerous
when people say that they feel better i
think it's very important for the people
who are listening at home to understand
this
right so
a person who does not feel well on a
plant-based diet
the reason they don't feel well is
because they have a damaged gut
this is the person who actually needs
fiber the most right they need to heal
their gut
but if you withdraw
and you avoid and you restrict
you are not healing the gut you are
instead
avoiding the entire thing
this would be like if i have a bad knee
right
i hurt my knee
i have two choices ellen
all right
in fact how about
for you you tell us what you would do
okay here are the two choices you just
hurt your knee
here's what you can do you can um stop
walking for the rest of your life
seriously yeah you won't feel the pain
right you will never feel pain in your
knee yeah i can promise you that yeah if
you just stop walking
yeah or flip side
you can i'll set you up with a great
physical therapist right and that
physical therapist will walk you through
a process
and you will
rehabilitate
strengthen and fortify that knee
and i i
have to tell you that there you may feel
some discomfort in that process
totally that's such a good example so
what are you gonna do because then yeah
of course the physical therapy because
the the end result is abundance and good
health and vitality throughout your
whole body not just like avoiding the
pain in the knee and then you no longer
have the pain in the knee it's exactly
true and so the person who avoids is
like the person who decides i'm not
gonna walk anymore and as a result of
that okay cool so you don't feel pain in
your knee you have accomplished that
but you're going to suffer other
consequences the legs the muscles above
the knee and below the knee are growing
weaker because you're no longer using
that knee
you are now gaining weight because
you're sedentary you're not moving
anymore
your metabolism falls out of whack now
you've increased your risk of having
coronary artery disease or diabetes
right and you go down the line we keep
going with this sort of analogy
everyone knows you would never do that
right right you work through the process
you build up the strength you get back
to you get you restore the functionality
and i'm saying to you this is exactly
the way the gut works
you can you can you might have to work
with a professional
gobo and slow
reintroduce these foods build strength
back up you may feel some discomfort in
that process because it's not so easy to
get through that whole process without
feeling even a single thing
but when you emerge on the other side
you're playing basketball again yeah and
you have that healing which is like the
last letter of your that acronym when
you have true healing yeah so the last
letter of the acronym is after you train
your gut
i just feel compelled to say this last
thing which is holistic healing
h stands for holistic healing
and this is a um recognition and
acceptance that like
you know i'm talking about the
microbiome and i'm talking about
food and it makes it sound like it's all
just biochemistry yeah and chemicals and
like you know food meets microbes and
and then like you know it happens right
that's completely ignoring the fact that
we are
real people
we have emotions
we have fears
concerns
we
those emotions those fears
our relationship with food
stress that we have in our life
um
trauma
uh hostility
these things ultimately can manifest in
the gut
and i think it's very important for
people to hear this and understand it
healing your gut is not just the food
that you eat
healing your gut is not just low and
slow
you have to look at the whole person
and when there are serious issues you
have to address those issues
so i want to share a quick story if
that's okay go for it okay
i had a patient who has ulcerative
colitis
and um
ulcerative colitis is an immune like
inflammatory immune-mediated
condition like basically you call it
autoimmune
that affects the large intestine the
colon
and these people they like basically
develop a raw red inflamed ulcerated
bleeding
colon right it's not pretty
and on top of that they like are pooping
constantly including in the middle of
the night
yeah like around the clock right and
they can't have a social life and
there's so many ways in which this
negatively affects them
and well these are the people who are in
a clinic with me and you know i'm
fighting to try to help them yeah this
patient of mine she had ulcerative
colitis and i was pulling out all my
tricks i was doing everything i could to
try to make her better
you know dietary approach
sleep exercise supplements like i was
doing everything
and
it was uh frustrating for both of us she
was not getting better
this went on for like
probably two years
um
and
then one day recently
she comes in and she goes
i have good news
i
am completely back
wow i feel like myself again
i don't feel like my life is being
dominated by a disease
i feel empowered
and i'm like jumping for joy yeah
and i'm just like so
like what
what was it yeah
and she says
uh i
was in a job
where i
hated going to work every single day
it was a hostile work environment and i
had a boss who would belittle me
in front of everyone else
and
she's like and i
realized that this had to be the reason
and i decided to take a chance
and i left that job and i took a new job
and they treat me with respect
and i look forward to work every day and
the people that i'm around
and when i did that
my issues went away
that's incredible
and i just i just think that it
illustrates the point which is that like
it's very easy for people to hear
my message
and i i want them to hear that this is
not just food
this is the whole human
this is where you are from an emotional
perspective this is your subconscious
this may be you grappling with wounds of
trauma from the past
this may be a separation because of
restrictive dietary patterns that you
perhaps have taken on
that
create food fear yep
and anxiety around your food like oh
gosh i don't know if i can eat that and
that anxiety like while you're eating
while you're eating is like a bad combo
is actually provoking your gut to get
upset right totally and there are
physiologic ways in which
our brain and our gut are connected to
one another
and they're constantly talking to one
another but when we're in in moments of
stress
our brain actually releases a hormone
called crh corticotropin releasing
hormone
which
spreads throughout the blood
but one of the things that's been shown
to do is it actually impacts directly
your gut microbiome
and this is ellen the reason why
many of us
when we're in times of stress we will we
will actually manifest that stress with
diarrhea or constipation or cramping
abdominal pain
or nausea
um food intolerances you know we
we manifest that stress through our gut
because of this physiologic mechanism
that exists right
and so the problem is when you have
like chronic perpetual stress
even something in the unconscious the
subconscious that's there causing stress
from the past yes
until we directly address it we're not
really ever going to be better this is
such a powerful message and i'm so all
about that because i'm huge on the
growth mindset and healing from your
traumas because it affects it affects
your everyday life and it affects your
health
on a day-to-day basis if you're getting
stressed out easily or if you're in a
really stressed out situation
um where you're not working at a
friendship or you're not working out
whatever it is in your life or a trauma
in the past like i totally see how
that's related to your gut health and
then your overall health because like
you expressed in the first episode how
it is correlated and related to
everything your hormone health and your
immune health and all of that so right
yeah it's so much more than food your
health is like all-encompassing and
that's why you're a little acromen
acronym
makes a lot of sense for the last one to
be holistic healing because it is so
much more than food it's all of it it's
like the balance in your life a hundred
percent and i think it's important to
take that into account is that don't
just turn this into like hey what do i
eat
make sure that you are taking care of
the whole person because like my patient
sometimes the solution ends up being
something completely unrelated to what's
on a fork right and actually the next
question i was going to ask you was what
about for people who have been eating a
plant predominant or plant exclusive
diet for a while and they're still
struggling with gut issues and it's like
well look to other areas of your life
how's the stress in your life how are
you feeling when you're sitting down to
eat your meal is your subconscious
telling you that maybe this isn't good
for me and i shouldn't be eating this
way or whatever
i totally agree with you i think that i
think that that's absolutely key and one
of the things that i've noticed
throughout my career very similar to
this patient that i'm describing um one
of the things that i've noticed
throughout my career is that the people
who are the most difficult to treat like
not they're not a difficult person these
are lovely people
but they're just not getting better
right and
um what has happened for me is that many
times i'm the one who ends up seeing
these people that have failed with other
doctors
and the solution is
most of the time
not tweaking their diet usually they're
trying really hard with their diet yeah
um and most of the time it's not like
hey
like could you get eight hours of sleep
and like wind down the electronics in
the evening and yeah get some exercise
like
what i tend to find is that
eventually
with enough time when we build a
trusting relationship like this is not
gonna happen the first time i meet them
right
but when we build a trusting
relationship what we ultimately discover
is that
there's usually something from the past
yeah that is kind of still there
and they might be kind of like
rationalizing in a way
like how i'm not worried about that yeah
that's not a problem for me anymore you
know
it could be uh trauma and my trauma to
me is a far more broad term than people
people often think the trauma only means
abuse
well first of all abuse can come in many
forms
um but also
trauma can be
anything where um
we
feel threat where we feel like we are um
in a hostile environment
and where we feel at risk
and it doesn't have to be happening
right now it could be something that
happened to you in the past it could be
the death of a parent
right or a loved one it could be uh an
emotional breakup or a divorce
it could be something to happen your kid
there's so many different ways we can
manifest trauma but the problem is that
it many times will like introduce
symptoms in our gut yeah and then a lot
of times it can affect like how you're
reacting to other situations in your
life which i think tends to be like one
of the biggest factors like if you have
this unhealed drama in your life or
multiple traumas and you're shoving it
under a rug but then you're showing up
in your present day life and reacting to
things on this hyper like stressed out
level because you're in this state of
what's this like you're in a state of
emergency almost in your brain because
you're not healed and you feel unsafe
and so when you're reacting and
experiencing relationships with people
let's say you go through
um like a hardship with a with a
relationship or something or just
anything any kind of trauma right then
it's gonna bring it back up and make it
that much harder to like have peace like
in your health and in your gut yeah
totally and and along these same lines
like our relationship with food is very
important right um i
feel for the person who
uh has an unhealthy relationship with
food because in my life food brings me
such tremendous joy yeah and that
unhealthy relationship can come in many
different forms it's not necessarily
something that meets the criteria for
anorexia nervosa or bulimia right you
know or avoiding restrictive food intake
disorder
it can come in many forms and it may
just be that you feel uneasy with
certain foods
that you feel fear of a food right right
that it's hard for you to enjoy the food
because of some sentiment that you have
around it
right but the problem is like when we
separate ourselves from our food now
food is causing anxiety
yes right and
so and then we will then
manifest those fears and anxiety
in our gut and it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy absolutely
so i think that these are things that
um in my experience in my clinic
like it's not just eat more plants
yeah with these particular things it's
let's create a plan
and let's actually turn our attention to
this issue let's acknowledge that it's
there yeah and turn our attention to
this issue and try to make it better and
it's all it's like has a very abundance
focus because like no one wants to be
eating a carnivore diet no one wants to
be eating like five foods i mean maybe
there are a few people but um people
don't want to be eating like five foods
they really like the idea of being able
to eat in abundance and a wide variety
and because that is how we're designed
to thrive
100 i mean think about the colors
the flavors
the textures um all herbs and spices are
plants
uh there's a reason that like when you
walk into your supermarket the first
thing that you see is the produce
section
it smells nice
it's colorful
we are designed to be attracted to that
yeah and um it's important from my
perspective to create pathways for
people who suffer with these issues to
number one understand
yeah and number two be empowered with
the plan
yeah to heal because the problem is that
that
reality is that you're not gonna get
this from your doctor
so what are your thoughts on gluten then
that's a common one that people feel
like they need to eliminate
um so i've talked about gluten in
significant detail in fiber fueled and i
talked about some more in the fiberfield
cookbook it was really good and
fascinating i
i want people to understand that like we
are vilifying this food yeah right we're
making it sound like it's impossible for
you to be healthy with gluten in your
life yeah
um so
that i don't believe to be true at all
there are different forms of gluten
containing foods
it's not the same eating white bread and
white crackers
compared to a like whole grain sourdough
bread right right these are very
different things
and um so it's also important for us to
look at the complete food now
if you have celiac disease
a person with celiac disease they have a
genetically motivated condition
that causes their immune system to
become activated when they consume
gluten containing foods right
these people like if i diagnose someone
with celiac disease
they are not allowed to eat gluten
ever again
there is no way for them to go low and
slow on gluten you can never reintroduce
it you have a genetic condition right
all right
but if we take people who have celiac
disease we move them to the side for a
moment
there are still a lot of people who make
the claim oh well when i eat going
containing foods i don't feel well
so what's going on there
well it's actually kind of interesting
on they did a research study where they
took this group of people who do not
have celiac disease they have gluten
intolerance
and they gave them three weeks worth of
breakfast bars
one week it was a placebo
one week it contained gluten
and one week it contained something that
is also in wheat
it's not gluten but it's called fructans
fructans are a fodmap
just like lactose
and fructans can cause
symptoms for people but also proteins
are probiotic they're good for our gut
microbiome
so like we actually want fructans
uh well anyway so they gave these three
weeks worth of bars and then they're
like randomized and the people didn't
know what week they were doing what how
do you sorry quick question how is the
placebo bar a placebo if it's actually a
granola bar what's a placebo about it uh
but they didn't add any additional
ingredients okay so like basically
granola bars at baseline
but one's got no additional ingredients
one's got gluten and one's got fructans
okay perfect okay so and then you do a
week and you record your symptoms how do
you feel at the beginning of the week
how do you feel at the end of the week
so here's what's interesting
when people again these are people who
have gluten intolerance
uh when people consumed the gluten
containing bar
they actually had less symptoms than
placebo
interesting let me say that again the
placebo was causing more symptoms than
the gluten how is that possible
because it's not the gluten right what
is it then it's the fructans okay so
when they ate the fructan containing
bars they got triggered okay and the
reason why is because the people who
have this gluten intolerance it's not
even specific to gluten it's that these
are people that have a damaged gut
like irritable bowel syndrome and so
they have a damaged gut and when they go
to contain to consume
these foods could be fructans from wheat
could be galactans and beans could be
fructose and fruit
could be lactose in dairy if you consume
dairy
when you consume these foods
it can cause digestive symptoms because
of the weakness in your gut and this is
where it's just a matter of healing the
gut
right so
um i i want people to understand that
the elimination of gluten containing
foods like you're throwing the baby out
with the bath water yeah like we
understand that like a white flour
tortilla or white bread is not going to
be health promoting like whole wheat
sourdough yeah or organic organic you
know organic whole wheat bread right um
but there's a problem you're throwing
the baby out with the bath water
because
the average american is not getting
anywhere close to the amount of whole
grains that they need in their diet
whole grains protect us from heart
disease and cancer
whole grains extend our life expectancy
yeah in research studies like they're
good i want tons of them right
and
the problem is that the number one whole
grain in the american diet is wheat
now that doesn't mean it has to be the
number one for you at home like you
don't have to have wheat as your number
one
but you do need whole grains to be
healthy from my perspective
and in the studies where people were
eliminating gluten
they actually increased their risk of
heart disease interesting so because
whole grains protect us from heart
disease
like we shouldn't be making dietary
choices that increase our risk of our
number one killer that's a horrible
decision
we should be making choices that reduce
our risk of the number one killer and
that's what consuming whole grains does
so if you choose to go gluten-free
that's okay
but if you choose to go gluten free i
desperately want you to ramp up your
whole grains like
sorghum teff quinoa amaranth you go down
the line there's a number of different
whole grains that are gluten free right
or you can possibly do the growth um
acronym to try to like reintroduce it
and become accustomed to it 100 and like
for example if you eat whole wheat
sourdough so if you think you have
gluten intolerance
try sourdough
and report back to me and tell me what
went down
because sourdough is lower on fodmaps
and sourdough is also lower on gluten
interesting so health promoting food
okay so to kind of round out this
conversation
you're promoting a wide variety of whole
plant foods as optimal for our
well-being not only our gut health but i
guess because it is good for our gut
health it promotes the health of the
rest of our body for longevity
preventing heart disease things like
that someone might be listening to this
who is like on the fence of like well i
feel like eating um maybe a lot of
animal foods people are mostly on board
i think listening to this are
um in agreement that like avoiding ultra
processed foods but like animal foods
might be like well maybe i can eat you
know plant foods and plenty of animal
foods is there a way to get
lots of a wide variety like you're
talking about that as many as you
feel like it's optimal for our health
and still eat
like a lot of animal foods or do you
feel like this by definition means that
we need to be plant predominant or plant
exclusive
if you took
the
60 of our calories that are ultra
processed foods
and you replaced them entirely with
plants
that would make you 70 plant-based
that's actually a great start right and
you know my
perspective is this
um
i was
less than five percent plant-based
for most of my life
wow
and
so
i'm like not trying to message the
person who's already 95 plant-based
you've got a healthy diet
i'm trying to get up with the person
who's five percent plant-based and i'm
trying to get them to 20.
and i celebrate
every single step on that path
my philosophy is progress over
perfection
don't feel overwhelmed by like some
arbitrary number that you and i are
talking about today yes i want people to
hear this and say oh dr b is pl is is
basically creating a path forward for
better health
through abundance yes take that path
and give me two steps
and that is progress that i celebrate
and if you get yourself to 70
you're on a good path and what's gonna
happen is you're gonna feel so much
better
and you're gonna want more and i just
don't see any value to the animal foods
i don't i don't know why we have too
many studies that indicate that they
increase our risk of disease and shorten
our life expectancy
so i don't know why you would choose to
keep them in there particularly at the
amount that people are currently
consuming where it's more than their
body weight or sometimes now even like
trendy types of eating patterns are like
even more than 30 maybe even 50 percent
maybe 70 of your calories from animal
foods yeah totally and these are like
you know we all like complain about fad
diets but then we jump on board the new
trend
where's the research right we have an
overwhelming amount of research that
indicates to us that when you consume a
plant-based diet you don't have to make
compromises that is not going to just to
be transparent and clear about this
though that is not going to end up being
a 100
plant exclusive diet for every single
person and i welcome that right i
welcome everyone who wants to walk this
path with you and i yeah and you and i
when we walked this path
it changed our life so much that we took
it all the way so much oh my gosh 100
and that's a beautiful thing because not
only is it good for us
but it's also good for the planet right
and it's good for the animals
and from an ethical position
it feels really good to be able to say
that right it really does it's like very
well-rounded and there's so many reasons
it doesn't stop at just one well i
started out for my health once learning
about like the planetary effects and
then
like taking into consideration the
animals i'm like wow this is really it's
really a no-brainer right but you know i
i don't think it's possible to be
healthy and consume animal products the
way that we're currently doing it i just
don't
i think they have to be reduced how far
you choose to reduce them as a personal
choice again like i want a very
inclusive form of plant-based where
everyone feels welcome and everyone's
engaging in the plant party
together i love that so it's not so like
oh man i'm not doing it all the way but
i'm not even dry
that's that that is um letting
perfection stand in the way of doing
something that's really great for
yourself right and you know perfect does
not exist
it's a figment of the human mind totally
and so why are we chasing that that
makes no sense let's just love it enjoy
progress together and let's celebrate i
love this approach because the way that
you talk about like this way of eating
is also very holistic with your mindset
as well of looking at it in a form of
abundance and
welcoming everyone and not being like
quite so dogmatic as you know maybe it
can become for some people and when you
look at it this way i feel like it
really does help
open the doors for people and help
people relax helps their stress levels
which in turn helps your gut well i
totally i totally agree with you i think
that what you said about the stress
levels is an important point too because
like when people get um
so fixated
that
the imperfections of their diet cause
them stress
then you are not where we want you to be
right now
totally
totally yes and actually i do know
multiple people who that was a reason
for them that took into consideration
how they were going to eat but i really
do believe in the power of the mind and
how you can heal
from any kind of limiting mindset and
kind of move forward that way so that
like when you are eating a well-planned
diet um that you're also feeling good in
your mind as well totally that's that's
that and that's the way that we all
deserve i honestly feel that
i i wish for every single person who is
listening to us today that they can find
a diet that empowers them that brings
them great joy that they are passionate
about that they don't need to make
compromises and that it actually
contributes to a longer healthier life
that's really what i want yeah and then
long term it just becomes like the back
of your hand like like for me i like
barely even have to think about it
because it's so second nature at this
point so everyone listening please go
get your new book new second book i
cannot wait to read it and we'll be
getting it very soon
yep the fiber fields cookbook uh
i
so
i i really am getting the same vibes
that i had with fiber fueled
which is that i feel like this is a game
changer and i can't wait to see it out
in the world
you and i are recording this before the
book comes out but it's coming out like
shortly after the book is out so you
guys when you're hearing this
the book is available now
and like no matter where you are in the
spectrum of what we're talking about
today whether you have food intolerances
or you do not
we all are
joined together on the same mission
which is to eat more plants and
diversity in abundance and this book is
designed to help you to do that amazing
so 125 recipes full color photography
you will find out how many plant points
like that's a measure of diversity
on every single meal but if you have
food intolerances using the growth
strategy i will teach you how to fix
that right and i actually have two
protocols that are recipe based built
into the book
and then finally like
you want sourdough i actually teach you
how to make it
um you want sprouts i'll teach you how
to do that too fermented food cool
that's in there also so
basically this is like a tool kit for
gut health
you will find what you need and it's
just a matter of implementing it in your
own life in a way that makes you very
happy amazing great well let's round it
out there and i will put the links below
for people to check out your new book
thank you so much all right bye
[Music]
you